but first we begin with the pressing
issue of the moment now we're just two
hours away from a government shutdown
and this is all happening just so you
get this because Democrats are holding
up a spending bill holding it hostage
for their demand for amnesty for
dreamers connecting the two they should
not be connected to get inside the story
let's go to Senator James Lankford a
Republican from Oklahoma who is about to
go on that floor and vote senator
Lankford it's great to see you you're on
radio this morning you're on with me now
really appreciate your time tell us
where things stand now after that
meeting that the President had with
Chuck Schumer we understand only general
Kelly was in the room with the president
and Schumer no other staffer of Schumer
was I guess allowed in or I didn't bring
him yeah I'm not sure I was I wasn't
invited in that meeting either but what
we understand from that meeting is that
Chuck Schumer brought a whole list of
demands that he wanted to be able to see
be addressed and the president told the
mayor this is a legislative branch issue
you go work this out with the Speaker of
the House and the majority leader of the
Senate while y'all work out y'all go
work out but I'm not gonna go intervene
and try to be able to tell them what to
do and so he basically turned Senator
Schumer right back around send him back
to Capitol Hill and said y'all work that
out now wait a second he shows up with a
list of demands this is after that
disaster visit that Senator Graham and
Senator Durbin had to the Oval where
they go in and present this great deal
it's the flake Durbin Graham amnesty
deal they go over and present this thing
it increases chain migration and it
actually puts more pressure senator
Lankford on the border because you don't
get the money that the president
requested for the border so the two
things that the president really cared
about it they actually exacerbate and on
the diversity lottery issue they
actually just take the diversity lottery
recipients and they transfer at least
half of them to the other protected
status category so on a pretty much
every front they did not even really
move to the president's position and now
they're actually asking for more demands
only so and again you left out one
simple thing in that as well on Tuesday
they had laid out a process for how we
were gonna actually come to conclusion
on this and on Thursday of that week
that came in and said we want to go
around the process we just agreed to on
Tuesday so again the president was
having none of it he sent them right
back to the hill this is where it has to
be negotiating has to be actually
resolved and at the end of the day all
of this conversation about dr. really
should be a conversation about border
security that's the thing that's missing
we do not have a docker problem we do
not have an illegal immigration problem
if we actually have good border secure
exactly and Senator what's what's wild
about this is that we litigated this
issue in the 2016 election cycle Donald
Trump won Lindsey Graham dropped out in
December of 2015 he was so popular he
knew he couldn't even win his own state
of South Carolina
obviously Marco Rubio Jeb Bush much more
liberal toward immigration they didn't
go anywhere Donald Trump wins and yet
we're still we still have Republicans
like Lindsey Graham god bless him you
know banding together with dick Durbin
and Jeff Flake who didn't even vote for
President Trump to try to push this
issue again it looks like this is
crazytown stuff the president will not
go along with this and yet Lindsey
Graham and I want to play this for you
senator is out there attacking your
colleague Tom cotton and Stephen Miller
at the White House let's listen the
Stephen Miller approach to immigration
has no viability Tuesday the president
was in a good place he was the president
of all of us he spoke compassionately
about immigration tough on security
wanted bipartisanship two days later
there was a major change I think the
change comes about from people like mr.
Miller the Tom cotton approach has no
viability here you know he's become sort
of this state king of the Senate
well cotton responded by saying you know
I bet I could win my home state or
something like that in presidential
election a guy who couldn't win his home
state I thought that was a really cheap
shot by Senator Graham again an issue
that he is way outside the mainstream of
the core Trump supporters out there who
pushed who pushed him over the finish
line to help him win right and I would
say I was in the meeting on Tuesday
and I don't know what I wasn't in that
meeting on Thursday but President Trump
was pretty clear on this in fact he was
very clear on that last October and has
been interesting to me to hear the
number of Democrats here in the last 24
hours have said the president won't tell
us what he wants on immigration that is
not true
last October the president put out a
very lengthy document here's what he's
looking for on immigration that was four
months ago they can't say he didn't give
him anything they just didn't like what
he gave them it's very different reading
I didn't like it and I never got it we
definitely got it he got it all laid out
and I would expect the President to lay
out another proposal and to be able to
give legislative language here in the
next probably 72 hours next four days or
so to be able to say this is what we're
looking for they're able to move it but
he's been clear on the good light bill
and on things that are moving in the
Senate to say this is the idea yeah we
had Labrador on last night Labrador and
good luck bill and on January 10th the
White House said we support that bill
and then Mitch McConnell comes out two
days ago and says well we don't really
know what the president stands for the
whole thing confuses me by the way the
Democrats don't get off the hook on a
shutdown here's the CNN poll just came
out which do you think is more important
for Congress to do avoid a government
shutdown 56 percent continued daca only
34 percent senator Lankford a ABC
Washington Post poll said that who do
you think is responsible for a possible
shutdown Republicans 48% Democrats in
Congress 28% both equally 18%
Republicans in one poll don't fare all
that well on who's to blame for the
shutdown yet boy it seems like the
American people don't want this
government to shut down for illegal
immigrants I can tell you that
yeah it's remarkable that we should not
have a shutdown over something that has
a deadline on an immigration
conversation of March the fifth in the
middle of January that that is not even
rational to be able to connect the two
at this point by any means and the other
thing it's always interesting to me is
when Republicans were in the minority
they were blamed for the shutdown when
Democrats are the minority Republicans
are blamed for the shutdown so that is
the media just pushing out the constant
message there's no way Democrats are
trying to do this when it is it was the
same thing during the Reagan
administration Tip O'Neill shut down the
government three times on President
Reagan but Reagan was blamed for the
shutdown every time so we get the
narrative we understand the the what
what happens with this no one wants to
shut down because it destabilizes every
federal employee every institution
that's
to get a permit that's trying to be able
to do whatever it is that they have to
connect with the federal government it's
not healthy it's not good for us it
doesn't save money but we constantly get
to blame no matter what actually happens
with it sorry senator Lankford it's not
even as fun as 2013 because we don't
have any dr. Seuss readings scheduled as
far as I can tell unless you're going to
share something with us right now any
poetry any songs anything it is bedtime
for a lot of children around the country
but they're not going to get story for
me get it from their own dad all right
senator Lankford thanks so much for
joining us